MATTHEWS.
CUT OFF BY FOX.
AND PLAYED OUT TO CENTRE.AGAIN,
MARK.
THAT THESE GUYS VERY OWDER GETT
GOT A GOOD LOOK. POINT WITH THE
BACK.
STOPPED BY JERRY.
THERE IS SOME NEW FACES.
O'CONNOR GETS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
AND HE WOULDN'T BE AWARE OF.
YOU'RE NO ON.
8:58E
SECOND PERIOD FOR MATT ZALESKI..
TROUBA HAS GOT A LEFT-HANDED
STICK.THIS OVERTIME.
>> HE D BY THE NET.
DEFLECTED AWAY.
BOUNCING PUCK.
AND IT'S CLEARED IGOR!
IGOR!DOWN.
>> Brian: TRYING DEPTH
PERCEPTION
>> Joe: THERE'S THE ATTEMPTED
PASS.
THEY READ IT..EVER SEEN.
PLAYERS LIKE THAT.
EVGENI MALKIN FOR HEINEN.
WHAT A SAVE, WITH THE GLOVE BY
SHESTERKIN.A NICE MOVE.
HE TAKES IT OUT FRONT.
HE IS CUT
IN.
GRAVES TO SEVERSON.
>> Sam: 12:17
SIDE, IN THERERBARRON IS STOTO ?
THAT IS ANOTHER ONE.
NOT A ASEE
THIS.
HE'S FOLLOWING TOO CLOSELY
>> Ray: SINCE THIS GAMEIT.
QUICK SHOT STAMKOS.
GOOD LOCK OUT FRONT OF THE BY
DE LOOKING MALKIN.
GOALS IN THE LAST 19
OPPORTUNITIES HE CAN-- HOW MANY
BREAK AWAYS HAS ADAM LOWRY SHOT.
MARK GIORDANO DROPPING IT OFF
THAT GOAL THREE.
SHESTERKIN LOOKS TO CLEAR.MSELF
IN GAME  FOOTE THE EDGE OF THE .
FOUR--
>> Eddie: HE'S MADE A COUPLE OF
BIG STOPS IN THE SECOND PERIOD.
>> Kenny: REINHART BAC WALL, NO.
BEAUTY BY IGOR
>> Kenny: PAUL WENRAIGHT OFF OF
THE FIRST TWO GAMES AT RALEIGH..
PERRY FOR THE LIGHTNING, STOP!
BRILLIANT SAVE B
2012.
PAD TO
MAKE THE FIRST SAVE ANDF BENNET.
BY VASILEVSKIY.
NICE TIP BY BENNSTERKIN.
THE CANES TRYING TO ANSWER
QUICKLY.